hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast accelerated data workflows for
biomarkers discovery and metabolomics
clinical research applications in cystic
fibrosis research
I am Marjorie Torres elaborate and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
boots and sponsored by agilent
technologies as one is a leader in life
sciences diagnostics and applied
chemical markets for more information
please visit www.dent.umich.edu/license
or try to ask as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems for
Ewing or here in this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problems through
the green Q&A button lower left this is
a magic a tional webinar and thus offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click on the
CD button located in the bottom left
hand corner of your webpage and follow
the process of obtaining your credit I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker Phillip Britt Smith cubed
dr. Brits McKibben is a professor at the
Department of Chemistry in chemical
biology and Cystic Fibrosis canada
researcher visit McMaster University
prior to starting his career in position
he completed his doctorate research with
David DUI Chen at the University of
British Columbia followed by a visiting
lecturer position at the University of
North Carolina at Greensboro and at post
doctoral fellowships which they wrote
Arabic at himeji Institute of Technology
in Japan his research interests in bio
and analytical chemistry and
metabolomics include the design of new
analytical strategies to quantify and
identify matter metabolites in by
samples using innovative preparation
mass spectrometric and bioinformatic
tools
so it's laboratory able to discover new
biochemical markers should support early
detection and treatment of human
diseases relevant to population or
occupational health and pediatric or
perinatal medicine with emphasis on
inherited metabolic disorders and
developmental origins of health and
disease the dr. Fritz McKinnon's full
bio please see lab boots calm I will now
turn it over to dr. blitz MacKinnon for
his presentation Hey Thank You Marjorie
for the introduction and welcome
everyone to my presentation which is our
great pleasure to share with you some of
our recent developments in developing
high-throughput
metabolite screening technologies based
on capillary electrophoresis mass
spectrometry these will be aimed
primarily to interrogate volume
restricted samples that are quite
unusual including red blood spot cutout
samples as well as sweat samples from
one month old in infants were screened
positive for cystic fibrosis and
although the focus will be mainly on
biomarker discovery by markers not only
for diagnostic or prognosis of diseases
but actually to provide new insights in
terms of disease pathophysiology with
that I want to highlight that this a lot
of this work is Asha collaborative in
nature including a number of partners
from newborn screening Ontario from
agilent technologies from the Hospital
for Sick Children in Toronto as well as
Children's Hospital here at McMaster
University funding has been critical for
this type of work including from n circ
CHR and in particular cystic fibrosis
Canada so this just gives you look at an
outline in terms of some of the learning
outcomes but also an overview of the
themes of my talk first and foremost I
want to highlight and define what my
table looks actually is and often many
researchers struggle between the
differences to emphasize in terms of
targeted or expanded targeted analysis
that's often
apophysis driven in contrast to non
targeted hypothesis-generating
metabolite profiling in many cases we
actually apply both approaches to our
data workflow secondly one big issue
that we're trying to over
come in the Taba lumix unlike other
omics technology is how to improve
sample throughput yet at the same time
maintain data quality and/or one of our
solutions towards that is how to develop
multiplex separations circle through
serial injections and how that can be
used as a fine phonetic tool to enhance
the quality for discovery for biomarkers
of relevance to clinical chemistry
certainly another big I guess challenge
in the field is how to identify unknown
five markers of clinical significance
and how to reduce any bias or sampling
artifacts that can come out of that
fourthly and particularly relevant to
cystic fibrosis is what is in human
sweat how can we use non target analysis
to characterize sweat and how that can
be useful to understand again the
fundamentals of the disease
pathophysiology and could that be useful
to go beyond sweat chloride to
understand how the disease progresses
and how it varies from individuals even
with the same genotype so the templates
might be considered a I guess a modern
functional genomic tool that really was
developed and coined in the late to 90s
really to the advent of mass
spectrometry NMR and computer technology
however you can trace the origins of
metallics back to 120 years ago so
through the pioneering work through to
Sir Archibald Garrod
who first basically coined the this
notion of inborn error of metabolism and
you can see with this publication
introduced the idea of almost like
precision medicine how you can do
chemical analysis of urine samples to
individualize diagnosis in this case
diagnosis for a rare metabolic disorder
called captain Rio in this case you can
see that the phenotype the phenotype is
clearly present from the presence of a
dark urine and the origin for that
actually was traced to a small chemical
in this case homogeneous t'k acid which
later oxidized to produce is very
pronounced phenotype but through this
discovery he was able to use this to
understand the disease from a
mechanistic standpoint but also as a
essential diagnostic tool at the same
time so this is way beyond before the
discovery of the gene DNA before the
advent of mass spectrometry you can see
the origins of Intel Linux really goes
back quite far um from the pioneering
work of Sir Archibald Garrod nowadays
the preventative screening for rare
genetic disorders is now - done through
universally through newborn screening
programs that's applied in most
developed countries for example since
the early 60s the pioneering work of Bob
Guthrie through the development of
simple collection mechanisms who's a
paper filter cards and develop that new
assay is to screen for rare metabolic
disorders like phenylketonuria has
really revolutionized preventive health
nowadays in the last twenty years with
the advent of tendon mass spectrometry
now one can actually screen in a
multiplex fashion collectively a large
number of rare metabolic disorders and
really the main theme here is early
detection or pre-symptomatic diagnosis
of rare but yet treatable genetic
disorders this all can be done in the
cost-effective manner through ten and
mass spectrometry um so how does this
relate to cystic fibrosis CF was
recommended to be included in the panel
of genetic disorders to be screened for
about so now about ten years ago or so
however it actually doesn't rely in mass
spectrometry it has a very unusual
screening approach and we'll talk about
that and some limitations behind that
essentially several limitations with
cystic fibrosis screening is that it has
very poor positive particular accuracy
it basically identifies a lot of
carriers who are not affected with the
disorder you can see typically in the
province of Ontario where cystic
fibrosis has been screened for less it's
nine years or so typically of the
population born each year roughly about
thirty for authentic doses cases are
identified each year but that's only a
fraction of the screen positives most of
them are carriers who are not affected
so if we just look at the screening
algorithm that supply for cystic
fibrosis in most jurisdictions in north
america it's a two-tiered approach
essentially it starts off with an
immunoassay for a pancreatic enzyme
called the immuno reactive tristan
trypsinogen
this particular enzyme is quite
sensitive for CF but is not specific you
can see that the positive attitude value
overall is quite low in order to improve
specificity any screen positives for IRT
that exceed a cut-off will then be
screened for a collection of known
mutation panels a mutation panel for
known mutation disease-causing mutations
for CFTR in this case it varies from
jurisdiction to jurisdiction but
typically after those two two screen
approaches any screen positive case will
then be moved on to a confirmatory
screen based on sweat chloride so this
is an unusual test but this is the gold
standard for cystic fibrosis screening
however you can see there's actually
some clinical challenges with this
screen approach so first and foremost
least in the province of Ontario they
categorized the screen positive cases in
terms of three categories a B and C they
are typically classic CF cases with two
disease-causing mutations and high rrt
in most cases they're authentic CF cases
but to prevent any false screen
negatives they actually include these
two other categories that have either
one or no mutations or high or very high
levels of IRT the problem with that is
you start identifying carriers and what
it turns out to be is of all the CF
screen positive cases that go for sweat
chloride testing only 10 to 15% of cases
or our authentic CF cases the vast
majority
85% typically are screen negative they
have low sweat chloride below 29
millimolar is the cutoff typically
whoever there's actually another
category so you identify cases that are
inconclusive or and egress they have
intermediate sweat chloride cases so you
can see the CF screening approach and
it's even the Diagnostics are still
challenging in terms of what to do when
you start screening the mass scale
especially relatively rare mutations
cases or rare phenotypes of the disease
and this is reiterates next slide here
just showing that CS although to
consider the classic
mono genetic disease it's actually quite
complex and how its expressed it depends
on many gene modifiers and it's ected by
environment as well and it's really
disease spectrum so you have the classic
you have cases with very low residual
function functional activity of CTR
which conducts primarily the chloride
but there's also intermediate cases as
well as we saw with the intermediate
sweat chloride cases and although sweat
chloride does a good job to discriminate
between the CF cases relative to non CF
cases there are these intermediate
categories as well fermion hypothesis
was with these sweat samples obtained
from the infants that are screened
positive whether potentially other
markers that might help us understand
disease and how it progresses but also
as a secondary test as well but also can
might help alleviate and understand
these intermediate cases in terms of
which ones will progress into CS or not
so this was the main focus of our study
in this particular case so moving on to
metabolomics for those who are not not
familiar with it I guess it's really
referred to as the comprehensive a
non-target analysis of all small
molecules typically under about a
thousand Dalton's or so and the big
promise of entitlements it's is it's
functional reactive in terms of its
close association with phenotype as you
saw in the previous slide in the case
for a captain area with black urine
samples and importantly to physiology as
well and and this really has taken a
backseat probably the last 40 years
because of the advent of Malcolm Balaji
metabolomic ANSI here is are not just
building blocks for biopolymers but
they're actually bioactive compounds the
doggedness metabolize but not only dodge
metabolites from the cell but actually
what's really interesting with the tabla
makes you expand the definition it
actually includes environmental and
dietary compounds as well so the quite
extensive quite complex individually but
they really are at the interface between
environment and lifestyle and phenotype
and physiology and are closely
associated of course with gene
expression that's just I guess a strong
interest in the tabla mix technologies
but as you'll see shortly the technology
used to do the tablet profile is quite
distinct and quite different from the
other mix platforms and really is no
standard approach for doing
comprehensive metabolizes but typically
depending on the type of bio fluid or
tissue sample that you
to analyze which can be anything from
plasma to urine to in our case physical
interested in these very small amounts
of sweat from infants or cutouts and
fried blood spots typically most people
consider either an NMR base metabolic
profile that is quite robust
quantitative and allows for
identification of compounds however
unfortunately because of the low
sensitivity of proton NMR in most cases
the coverage of the metal is quite
limited however for long-term studies is
a very robust platform it's it's quite
favored in that particular context in
contrast there's a growing sort of
interests in mass spec based metal on
the platforms typically using various
types of mass analyzers often the time
of flight to kyouto systems to Orbitrap
systems and other mass analyzers you can
see that the configuration used for
ionization could be different if I dab
it but typically electrospray ionisation
and you can see the configurations for
separation before mass spectrometry
could either be direct and fusion if you
using high resolution mass spec or Vera
separation platforms including LC GC and
the focus of this talk will be some of
the I guess advantages of using
capillary electrophoresis as a very
unique high efficiency separation
platform that's micro scale but I can
allow you to do a lot of interesting
guest approaches to improve sample
throughput and data quality but
typically the weak the weakness of mass
spectrometry is typically associate with
the ionization source so it's generally
less robust identification of knowns
it's definitely more of a challenge even
with tiny mass spec and high resolution
mass spectrometry however mass spec has
a benefit of higher sensitivity and
generally broader coverage but again in
many cases you have to use you have to
consider multiple separation platforms
to get the best overall coverage so
there's no one solution essentially
Crippen tablet linux and you have to
consider multiple platforms depending on
the scope and coverage that you desire
if it was just this the analysis itself
that was the only issue then no problems
could be manageable but like other omics
it really have to consider the big
picture so including the pre analytics
involved with the study design how the
action as performed the type of samples
collected of course standard operating
protocols to avoid bias sample
transportation storage preparation you
want to ideally have very simple simple
sample prep to minimize any potential
bias or improve precision and then the
post analysis challenges in terms of
processing this is a big issue in
bottleneck for especially non targeted
metabolite analysis and ultimately how
to interpret those results so you can
see in terms of the big picture the
tabla mix has considerable challenges
and it's more than just a analytical
chemist that are involved with it but
you have to have good expertise and
certainly by informatics and study
designs moving on one thing that we're
trying to overcome in metabolomic is
typically if you're using separations
coupled to mass spectrometry that tend
to be low throughput and they involve
complicated data processing steps as
well that lead to bias and they're not
really suitable for large-scale
etymological studies so we've been too
focused on developing faster more robust
and low-cost screening approaches that
allow for non-target analysis for buy
more discovery but in particular apply
for very small amounts of samples as we
said as we mentioned earlier with dried
blood spot extracts or sweat samples
from infants and then this is just over
the gives you an overview of the
challenges the Triad here is how you
maximize sensitivity or metabolomic
coverage well again enhancing
selectivity and resolution while at the
same time trying to address issues with
sample throughput and cost and
minimizing cost so very difficult to
find a single platform that can
basically address all three issues as
well however we think that our platform
is does do a really particularly good
job if you're certainly if you're
separating ionic and polar metabolites
in particular and especially if you're
dealing with very small amounts or
volume or stricted samples or small
amounts of tissue or cell numbers as
well and typically involves very minimal
sample processing but you can see in the
top left quadrant here the seee is a
really simple separation technique it's
just essentially a hollow tube where you
apply a voltage with the buffer and you
can see that ions are separated based on
their electric
mobility which reflects are essentially
effective charges size ratio essentially
smaller cations move faster than larger
cations highly charged ions move faster
than millimeters ions the interface for
CMS typically uses a coaxial sheet that
interface which is a basically it has a
nibble Iser gas flow with a make up flow
or sheath liquid that forms a stable
spray to again ionize ions in the gas
phase one thing to really highlight here
is that the separation occurs under
isocratic conditions so constant
composition more importantly the sheath
liquid and the interface also provides
constant composition for ionization
these are - these are two important
issues or I guess elements of the
technique that allow us to do the
multiplexing which I'll talk about
briefly and question here that picture
on the right side here this is not our
particular lab but a lab in Japan where
their answer to sample throughput is
simply to purchase more equipment and
run things in massively in parallel that
was a really wasn't a feasible approach
in our particular case and our question
is how can we get more value out of our
mass spectrometer by multiplexing
separation a done now in series before I
do that this gives an example of the
type of metabolites you can typically
measure this is from a urine sample for
example for biobank samples when volumes
are quite constrained against CMS is
quite useful in that case we can make
use of even down to five or less my
glitters of sample but you can see the
variety of metabolites that could be
analyzed in urine with simply a dilution
step so the sample prep is very
straightforward and each individual
metabolite has been studied individually
in ependymal studies as risk factors for
chronic diseases ranging from diabetes
to cardiovascular diseases as well and
what's nice about metabolomic of urged
by by CMS essentially is you can assess
not only nutrients but also
environmental factors including intake
of polyphenols by the excretion of poly
polygala
sulfate as you can see in the bottom of
the case here and you can look at drug
intake or alcohol intake as well
all these lifestyle factors that we know
are quite important in terms of disease
risk assessment the next slide here just
shows you essentially the principle of
the technique that we developed so
essentially most separations inject on
the column one single sample you'll loot
it often with the gradient elution you
recondition the column and repeat color
this process is quite low throughput and
involves a lots of complications when
you're processing large numbers of
samples including time alignment issues
we see what we essentially do you can
see in the top trace here we're simply
just injecting series of discrete sample
plugs that are buffered in between just
a buffer plug essentially interspersed
by buffer plugs this is a series of
hydrodynamic injections and you can see
that we're loading the capillary almost
a third of the computer with discrete
sample plugs essentially the second
trades too you can see below you apply
your voltage and now the separation
occurs and remember that this is under
steady state condition so under
continuous buffer so all the ions with
each respective sample will migrate with
the same ability essentially and if you
look at the bottom trace this is the
extracted Iowa two program and here you
can see three examples of metabolites
and you can see that they enter the ion
source that are offset in time by just a
few minutes and these are the same
samples being injected in this
particular case the second trace you can
see for the leucine isomer is what's
really nice about this technique you
increase throughput with the same
typical I guess analysis time let's say
say 20 to 30 minutes but more
importantly you still retain most of the
separation performance in terms of the
isomer resolution so 7 sample plugs you
have three isomers you have 21 result
Peaks things that Co migrate as long as
their mass is different you can then
resolve in the second dimension to the
time-of-flight mass spectrometer and the
time of flight is particularly very
robust moderate to high resolution
instrument that has fast that
acquisition is perfectly suited for this
type of technique especially for high
efficiency separations with C II
especially when you're multiplexing it
in series so you can see that there's no
modifications to the systems a very
simple approach to improve throughput
tray shows you in a good example of a
real plasma filtrate sample that's being
analyzed these are seven plasma filtrate
samples introduced again seven times in
the same Tipler in the same run with one
mass spectrometer and a good feature but
seee you can see in the total ilyitch
program this large bulk signature signal
here this is basically the Col illusion
of massive amounts of sodium that of
course is a major ion in most biological
samples this would lead to typical
suppression issues but because CII's
such a great the Salter a lot of the
inorganic ions migrate very fast prior
to most of the organic metabolites they
have slower mobilities so you can see in
the highlighted trace a top that all
these little needles the needles in the
haystack or then resolve from the bulk
salt essentially to avoid suppression
issues if you can strap those compounds
based on their accurate mass you can see
again you see seven consistent Peaks
they're being resolved all in that same
analysis time the electric osmotic flow
this this flow generated for neutral
compounds can see migrates at the very
end of the separation this includes even
EDTA other additives that are included
with the blood collection system which
would also lead to suppression issues so
this really works in it's not just like
analyzing the same samples repeatedly
what's really interesting is how you use
the multiplexing that reflects your
study design so in the top left trace
here you can see you can essentially
perform an external calibration a single
run right by simply injecting this
series of in this case lactic acid
vendor solutions so you can get a good
calibration performance the second trace
it's kind of interesting you can then
use the seven sample plugs to do
analysis as in this case this is
exercise intervention study involving
plasma samples and what you can see here
is the two first samples you see here
are the individual the same individual
in the resting state the placebo in the
treatise date this is the next two
samples here
this one over here you can see that this
is post exercise after high intensity
interval training as you'd expect you
have massive levels of lactic acid
buildup in the plasma which you can see
clearly in the signature and this is the
same individual and then you can see a
small treatment effect the treatments
from bicarbonate intervention and then
recovery three hours after exercise so
this is a temporal resolution of an
individual person undergoing exercise
and a treatment effect so this allows
you to really identify biomarkers in a
single run essentially that is
unambiguous and we can actually do
absolute quantification as well you can
see if you compare the lactic acid
measurements from an enzymatic si is
equal standing compared to our CMS
protocol very good correspondence both
in terms of passing public regression
and a percent difference plot as well
with minimal bias but overall pretty
consistent performance so you can do you
can increase the throughput you can
avoid suppression you retain most of the
benefits that separation n you can
potentially in most cases do absolute
quantification that's consistent with
alternative methods as well I'm just
moving on before we move on to the
sister BOCES case just given a few more
examples of what we can do with this
type of technique you can see in this
case we're going to actually inject
again seven samples discreetly in the
capillary essentially but in this case
we'll have pairs of samples injected you
can see the first pair the Green plugs
that are shown here
they'll be diluted in a certain trench
so a one to do two dilution pattern here
the second the second case here this
will be another say suspected disease
case but done in duplicate but in this
case you can see the differences we're
going to Lutz in the same pattern one to
one ratio and the third sample beyond
that this is done in a two-to-one
pattern and what's really nice about
this technique is within the same run
you can essentially include what we call
a quality control sample so within each
run this will be a
normal healthy pooled sample this will
be our reference essentially and this
approach just shows you the diversity of
the technique and it allows for
essentially an easy way to identify both
known markers but also unknown markers
in terms of non-target analysis so the
first case for Part B here you can see
there's no evidence of elevated filling
which would be indicative of such
alumina you can see the pattern is what
you would expect based on dilution
pattern the small differences that do
exist are just sympathy biological
variation and more importantly you can
compare disease controls relative to
relative to healthy control which is the
sample zero here at the end more
importantly you can see in Tracy in the
bottom left corner this is a profile
typically for phenylketonuria rpq here
it's very evident which is the biomarker
and which samples are elevated you can
see the middle pair are grossly elevated
by four-fold exceed the cutoff because
we can do absolute quantification as
well and you can see that they're
elevated both with respect to the
disease controls samples 1a 1b and 3a 3b
as well as a healthy control so you can
see within a single run you can get
unambiguous data and the same thing for
the other example for maple syrup urine
disease here the branched-chain amino
acids are classic markers for the
disease including leucine isoleucine as
well as valine and here you can see that
the you have elevation once again about
four-fold elevation of valine in the
sample that comes from a different
sample case which is clearly elevated in
the first pair of samples so we can
identify the origin of the sample
everything is elevated relative to
controls and more importantly you can
resolve an isobaric I in this case they
tame glycine which is not elevated in
the case for maple syrup urine disease
so we were able to validate our method
for known biomarkers for known in
Verna's or errors in metabolism so we
wanted to proceed see whether we can use
the same approach to identify new
markers for diseases that are currently
screened such as galactosemia
so this just shows you in another
example what we can do again by encoding
information
the separation it's similar to what you
do with as a sachet off labeling with
mass spectrometer here is temporal
encoding the separation and once again
what's really interesting in this case
for the galactosemia case this was what
we noticed in this case with a series of
Peaks that were only elevated in a
Galactus signal sample this is a
duplicate again care of samples that
were injected in that particular pattern
that's two to one pattern we didn't know
what those compounds we're actually the
the screen positive got to Sameer case
had an incidental increase of situaion
in fact whoever that was proven just an
incidental finding but if you see this
case here that what were these compounds
and basically these elevated compounds
were grossly elevated upwards of 30 fold
in fact well to the other controls and
here we use a two-top system to do
collision induced dissociation to
basically derive the molecular
fingerprint of the unknown compound and
the take-home message essentially is
rayless identify that this was actually
and gle acted amino acid and there's a
series of mino acids which were only
elevated in the particular case for
galactosemia
and the o-p-s da plot here just shows
you just highlights that the Glassman
case was quite unusual relative to the
other disease other inborn errors
metabolism as the helping neonates as
well and in particular the galactic
glycine and galactic the glutamic acid
were gross a little bit in both cases
relative to the other controls and this
sort of makes sense in the case of
disease because you have essentially
defect typically of the second enzyme
that processes galactose this is the
galactose phosphate your needle
transferase enzyme that leads to an
elevation of lactose and elevated
galactose then can lead to undesirable
effects and reactions with in this case
free amino acid pool in cells as well so
this just gives an example that this
approach can be useful for confirmatory
diagnosis or confirmatory screening of
known diseases and known biomarkers as
well as revealing new marker
that could potentially be applied for
for mass spec basically and as opposed
to enzyme based screens for galactosemia
so and just to wrap up here this just
shows you again what you can do with the
technique so because you can inject
multiple samples we can design really
interesting workflows here so this will
be a typical day operation for us to say
analyze 50 samples in actually in a half
a day essentially the first run we do is
simply would be a standard mixture you
can see a standard mixture with a blank
as our four sample and then repeat of
three samples again this is just a
quality check
then repeat the second run the second
one here will be a TC run this will be a
pooled serum sample and four serum or
four blood samples in particularly the
sample processing is pretty
straightforward just an ultra filtration
to remove protein and dilution step
essentially then for some experiments
three to eight you can see in this case
we include always a blank run so this
will just track for any sample carryover
effects and then a randomized analysis
of individual samples with again another
QC built in with each run essentially
and this is unusual because normally QC
s are done in metabolomic
workflow is often intermittently every
say five to ten runs or so but here we
have every run has a pooled sample this
will be important for Quality Assurance
purposes and then midway through our
runs we do a repeat number ten here of
QC run and then complete the workflow as
you see here so you can see there's very
various ways to improve the data quality
to analyze large number of samples but
at the same time with full Quality
Assurance this just gives you an example
what we would see from a typical Syrah
metabolite extract if you go back once
again first a run number two this will
be our total island for Graham the blue
trace and then below will be our
extracted eyelet row program say for a
compound such as 1000 allen key you can
see clearly have three again pooled
average spending levels found in the
serum we have a blank sample there's no
carryover effects no background issues
and then further repeat of three samples
again so that is a good signature that
runs our high quality but that needs a
we're effects and then we can begin say
if you go back to the run diagram here
say run number three would be your
randomized individual samples with the
blank and QC you can see that for two
ions in particular leucine and
isoleucine in this case you can see
seven plugs but one of the blank so you
see six samples in pairs because they're
isomers was twelve result Peaks you have
five individual patients here and a QC
will be four again an average pooled
sample from the population on the right
side you can see nominal maps that are
either barrack trimethylamine oxide and
glycine once again good separation
performance and you can only can see the
biological variation from sample to
sample and very good quality in terms of
a control chart here for now we're
pushing this to a thousand samples right
now the first cohort was a three hundred
samples plus sixty QC so you can see you
can have good measures of quality
assurance when even when you're doing
this multiplex injection approach with
good precision intermediate precision
that is okay so just to wrap up this
part of the introduction is we
essentially develop it I think I
modified and what we think is a
accelerated workflow for Varma discovery
that takes full advantage of the
multiplexing and I'll go back realize
this as we go through the CS Cystic
Fibrosis study okay so moving back to
cystic fibrosis and essentially our main
question is what is in sweat essentially
so besides electrolytes such as chloride
or sodium that's been measured in the
past that much is really well well
established in sweat especially from
infants that win month-old essentially
and our main question is whatever
metabolites might be associate with the
disease spectrum CF as we saw in the
past is not just one classic sort of
phenotype but different types of
phenotypes of different severity and the
sweat actually in this case is collected
through a process called pill or carbine
simulation I'm free sorry Phillip rope
instantly to iron Teresa's it's a very
quantitative route visible way to
collect sweat and topically from in a
non-invasive manner as well from even
young infants as well and you can see
that the sweat why salty sweat has
always been the hallmark of sister
processes any mutations that cause
impairments in sweat chloride reuptake
will then lead to basically a leakage of
chloride in the sweat which was again
still remains a classic gold standard
for cystic fibrosis screening so this is
a brief overview of our study design
because it's a rare disease we had to
pull samples from two pediatric
hospitals including sick kids in Toronto
as well as McMaster Children's Hospital
here in Hamilton we had a total of 50
non CF cases so these are all screen
positive cases if you remember with the
training algorithm the majority is 85
percent or so of screen positive CF
cases typically are either carriers or
false positives essentially so 50 of
these we had as primarily as carriers
but are not effective its disease and
then we had 18 authentic CF cases with
high sweat chloride with typically two
disease-causing mutations that were
identified and in most cases we're
making use of residual sweat samples
which sometimes we're less than 2 to 5
microliters or so so very small amounts
of sample remaining after the primary
chloride ometer measurements for
chloride measurement this just
reiterates the study design as was a
well balanced in terms of sex in terms
of site as well Agis were the same in
terms of confirmatory screening for CS
so sweat chloride tests one thing to
highlight that all these infants were
born normal birth weight no obvious sign
of cystic fibrosis so again this is all
about pre-symptomatic screening and
diagnosis of a disease
yeah normal birth weight the only
difference was and I'm like the level is
high AR RT and then a high sweat card in
particular but even you can see in the
case is for the cystic fibrosis infants
they're quite so heterogeneous just from
a pancreatic status that most of them
were the CF patients were packed very
insufficient but some of them had
moderate pancreatic function or were
actually sufficient in terms of
pancreatic status so you can see in the
CF cases are quite heterogeneous
themselves this just is an example of a
series of targeted assays we developed
for inorganic ions which are
established to the associated with again
defects in the CFTR which is primarily
searching assisting fibrosis this
actually highlights another strength of
sees that your you can measure and
separate anything from small polar inox
metabolites to inorganic ions to to
proteins really but in this case these
are targeted essays for compounds that
weren't detectable by mass spectrometry
in particular we we confirmed elevated
chloride as we expect including sodium
and what's interesting here is by a
sunny inorganic line that's not often
measured because it's at sort of little
micro molar levels but actually it's
quite important it's also co transported
by CFTR and any impairments in
thiocyanate transport can actually be
too important against lack of function
in terms of microbial activity because
the thiocyanate is oxidized by many
cells upon excretion to form this very
reactive hypothesis on eight clients so
there's many other compounds that are of
interest we can measure bicarbonate
which has been claimed to be transported
by the same protein we didn't find it be
differentiated between the CS and non CS
infants surprisingly however the main
focus here is what can we go beyond the
targeted known compounds or ions of
interest can we then expand that to
other compounds at at this point we
didn't know in advance were present and
sweat in this particular case all we did
was repeat the analysis with the
multiplex of serial injection in to
basically formats when render acidic
conditions typically one molar formic
acid with positive I mode this will be
for applied for analysis of cations and
sweater on it
ionic compounds and the repeat the
analysis separately for the same sweat
sample under alkaline condition that are
negative on mode and this is primarily
target for anions so each samples run
twice essentially in the next slide you
can see here so the first step is okay
how do we if we don't know what in sweat
how do we determine what compounds that
are consistently present and sweat that
we can measure reliably so and this is a
really nice feature of the what we call
the multi segment injection completed
the Trefusis mass spectrometry or MSI
CEMS if you remember
same format we're going to eject seven
serial plugs of sample in a single run
essentially but one of our first
experiments to do with a new sample that
that's unknown largely we do it what we
call a serial dilution trend filter so
we have a pooled sample that we
collected from all the infant's
essentially and that pooled sample will
be then be thoroughly diluted you can
see in the case for citrulline we're
going to dilute the sample fourfold in
two cases for the two first sample
injections injected then do a serial
dilution we include a blank of the six
sample injected and then the seventh
sample the last one is repeat of the
first two so essentially have a
triplicate injection of a pooled sweat
sample a diluted sample and then a blank
is on top of that and we do a mock the
feature extractor to extract all line
signals across the mass range that we
analyzed with our time-of-flight mass
spectrometer what we'll see is to
basically situations we'll have in one
case a classic signature you can see a
time results that matured that tells us
right away that this feature is precise
precisely measurable has a nice linear
trend and there's no background blank
contribution this particular case we
know what the compound is is citrulline
but in many cases we don't know what the
compound is we simply have an accurate
mass and the relative secretion time
that we annotate our samples with
conversely look at the rate race this is
a typical case of a spurious signal
which often is generated with
electrospray ionisation in fact the
majority of signals in electro spam
aspect are tend to be spurious in nature
and you can see by this approach we can
simply reject this on the signal
signature because it has no distinct
temporal pattern in this particular case
so by using this approach essentially we
can annotate all the metabolites that
satisfy three criteria again root
possibility good precision a linear
trend but more importantly no signal
from the blank and by doing so we'd be
able to interrogate again commonly
measured sweat samples sweat metabolites
present in the screen positive CF and
cents upwards actually originally about
74 compounds we've been restricted that
to 64 compounds because these were
largely present individual
samples more than three quarters of time
but in most cases the Euler cations or
anions many compounds were able to
identify other compounds had different
levels of confidence with identification
by moving on once we able to basically
come up with a targeted list of
compounds where we screened we filtered
out all the spurious signals we then do
the analysis again of the individual
samples but done if you remember before
in pairs of samples pairs that are
injected but with a distinctive dilution
pattern will also include a pool QC as
our reference and then repeat the
analysis in this way so these are
randomized pairs of samples of our
entire cohort that's analyzed and will
do either in a positive eye mode you can
see the signature for oxide prolene the
bottom-left trace compared to a negative
eye mode for acidic metabolites such as
lauric acid in this case lauric acid you
can see it's quite variable from person
to person some case is not detectable
and some individuals and highly present
and others as compared to auxochrome
which is much more consistently
measurable with lower biological
variations just a cut to the chase here
essentially is by using this approach
we've been able to identify a number of
lead markers besides sweat chloride or
fire sign a that distinguish again
CF infants from the non CF carriers
essentially that are unaffected with
disease one compound you can see in the
bottom a feature loading score here was
glutamine which you can see is was
elevated in CF much lower in sweat for
the non CF infants the one compound in
particular was interesting with an
unknown acidic metabolites and all we
knew in this case had an accurate mass
the role to migration time and had and
we didn't know what the structure was
essentially or is clinical significance
so that really spurned our efforts to
try and identify this unknown signature
in this case of course we're relying
primarily on using q talks to acquire
again whose induced Association
experiments and a fragmentation pattern
that in this case would allow us to help
elucidate the structure of the compound
and the top left trace just shows you
the challenges when you use mass spec
alone when you generate most likely
empirical formula even with good Massac
a mass error or low mass error you can
still generate
about thousands of potential chemical
structures from the chemspider database
search which of course would lead to a
lot of time to help identify the
compound tendon mass spec often a
product line scan in this case can help
if you can deduce the structure from its
characteristic fragments in this case
this compound were able to juice as
being actually a metabolite of the drug
used to stimulate the sweat namely a lot
of cryptic acid so this was quite
interesting and we actually had access
to an authentic standard in this
particular case we spiked it you can see
it co migrates we have good spectral
match of our tendon mass spectra 220
volts collisional of induced
dissociation of that collisional energy
so good matches and the negative ion
ms/ms spectra call migration so we're
very confident that this compound in
fact is pilla cryptic acid and what's
interesting is the infant's responded in
such a way that reflected that their
drug responsiveness reflected the
disease status and this was quite
surprising because it had nothing to do
really with CFTR function per se you can
see philippic acid in the top left trace
is was I guess was secreted at lower
levels in the CF patients compared to
non TF controls and what we speculate
essentially is we first had to deduce
that this was not a sampling artifact
maybe the hydrolysis occurred during
processing we actually looked at the
original gel pads that were used to
simulate sweat and collect sweat on
infants we extracted those and the
residual levels of local burgers it was
quite low so we're very confident that
the Flickr Picasa especially in the non
CF patients that are quite elevated were
in fact generated in situ from the sweat
gland itself in fact there is an enzyme
that's been associated with bedroll
assets of this lac Templar pentacle
arabic acid is called para oxidase and
I'll get back to this enzyme in the
context of CF later you know if we just
look at the data in its entire scope
here if you look at the original data
without any data transformation here
using non parametric statistical
analysis with multiple offices
correction as well for compounds were
consistently found as lead compounds to
discriminate between CF and non CF
infants once again Calatrava casa was
our lead compound with very good effect
size and
so change and passes bond for any
correction for that matter barging
blooming were two neutral amino acids
which were interesting to note as well
and the third compound here was
something very intriguing because it was
totally unexpected this is a mono methyl
heck so phthalic acid which you might
know is a metabolite of plasticizer that
were all exposed to this also is
interesting discovery essentially once
again from just elemental composition
you can generate thousands of potential
structures but in this case we had to
rely on a characteristic ms/ms spectra
to help us at lucid eight the structure
but before we did that we went back to
the data remember we do these runs the
QC runs that we do all the time each day
so you can see in this case the blank
sample was very low this so this
compound is not an artifact from the
background it has a very distinctive
dilution trend filter so we're confident
this compound can be measured reliably
so in a both the pool sample but also
individual samples and we know it's
acidic and essentially we deduced that
this compound in fact was this compound
below here this model EXO hetfield Falak
acid even this compound it's about a
mini metabolite you can see we can
easily do some differentiate them based
on the next spectra here so here we we
had a candidate we a shil was
commercially available were able to
purchase it spike it in our sweat sample
show demonstrate cool migration and very
good again ms/ms spectral match as well
that's about 90 percent for all the
fragments in terms the relative
intensities and in fact we had the same
mass spectra that was published as well
that was also a good confidence booster
for identifying this compound and so
what we speculate that this this
plasticizer in fact is likely
metabolized by the same enzyme that's
associate with the public or peen
hydrolysis as well and I'll get back to
that quite shortly as well first a
summarize once again the four lead
compounds in sweat that we've shown to
be differentiate between the CF and non
CF infants two compounds asparagine and
glutamine or so called endogenous
metabolites or nutrients they're likely
Co transported by transporters that are
dependent on sodium or chloride so we
weren't so much
interested in those compounds and they
had certainly have pretty good
discriminatory potential in terms of the
errand occurs well above 0.75 but was
really interested in these to exhaustion
of compounds which again we were able to
discover their exhaustion as compounds
yet they do reflect something about the
CF disease status but nothing in terms
of the CFTR function you can see in both
cases are consistently lower and the CF
sweat samples compared to the non CF
cases in fact both tilaka Pocasset in
NHP this plasticizer metabolites are
well correlated with each other from a
Spearman rank correlation plot as well
so we deduced that they're likely
metabolized by a common enzyme
essentially so how is this related to CF
this is a big I think discovery from
this work essentially is we have
evidence essentially that both these
exhaust compounds how the infant
responds to the drug used to stimulate
the sweat and how they metabolize
another mental toxin that's present
unusually likely exposed prenatally both
tell us that likely that in CF infants
have a deficiency in this enzyme called
para oxidase which the name suggests
that actually metabolizes xenobiotics
like pesticides in fact but also has
important roles in terms of mediating
inflammation and it's involved with
lipid metabolism as well and the more
work and literature research we've done
on this particular enzyme we've shown
that it's been long associate with
cystic fibrosis in fact and it actually
plays a really important role for
mediating biofilm formation because it
actually hydrolyzes the same Latin motif
so these quorum sensing molecules below
you can see above the biofilm image
there these are also lactams excreted by
say Pseudomonas aeruginosa and this just
shows you the interaction between the
hosts and the bacteria have big impacts
in terms of biofilm formation of course
is the hallmark of recurrent lung
infections and chronic lung infections
in statistics or both those cases but I
think we have some evidence we can infer
from our data that even infants at one
month old that are pre-symptomatic that
there's old there's also an evidence of
the deficiency
this enzyme that could be a potential
target for therapy as well and just to
end off this seminar it's going to talk
on one case study and this kind of I
guess weed rates the importance of
newborn screening program specially for
cystic fibrosis so this was a basically
an adolescent patient she was identified
symptomatically or diagnosed
symptomatically she was thirteen years
at the time of diagnosis so she was born
prior to the advent of newborn screening
for CF year in Ontario in the province
of Ontario so unfortunately she was
diagnosed quite late in life and most
likely involved rotations of different
specialists until she was identified or
diagnosed by a physician here in the CF
clinic at McMaster she actually had a CF
Giardino type it was actually eligible
for an interesting therapy called
potentiate errs this is I took after
work that's manufactured by vertex
she had this g55 1d mutation status
which quite responds to this therapy
that acts as a potentiate er in a
chaperone to improve function of safety
R so in this case we had repeat sweat
samples at the point of diagnosis you
can see in the table and top here
because she was at the point of
diagnosis quite underweight in terms of
body weight and height poor lung
function both from force sales volume at
one second and a forced vital capacity
as well and inspect cord you can see is
well above the 60 mm will have cut off
so classic CF in this case she then
underwent a classic or conventional CF
management including nutritional
supplementation and physiotherapy good
benefit here was increase in and body
weight and and but it no little change
in the lung function and they can see
the sweat chloride at the second time
point was quite this pretty much the
same with three months of the ivic after
a treatment with ongoing CF management
you can see it pronounced actually
improvement in the lung function and
more importantly you can see in the
bottom of the third column here that
there is a drastic reduction of sweat
chloride as well a good functional
indicator that this individual is quite
responsive to the therapy that led to
improve lung function so with these
three repeat samples from the one
well we basically wanted to interrogate
the sweat metabolome as we get with the
infants to see whether that there's
other signatures that reflect disease
responsiveness to both nutritional
intervention but more importantly with
the advent attend she ater and what
really stood out with the metabolites
where's two compounds in particular uric
acid you can see has a sudden increase
in sweat excretion just with the onset
of epoch after treatment and the bottom
xanthine you can see there's a dramatic
reduction of the sweat chloride sort of
the sweat xanthine excretion in these
individual patient in fact uric acid and
xanthine of course or substrate and
product of an enzyme called xanthine
oxidase so from this disciplinary study
we've shown some evidence that this Abba
copter and only acts as a potentiate ER
for cftr but potentially can actually
activate xanthine oxidase which also is
quite important for mediating oxygen
stress and inflammation as well and some
of these other markers including as far
gene in MHP that we saw with the infants
are also quite responsive markers not
only from the infant standpoint but also
from older children undergoing
therapeutic intervention with that I
want to end off hopefully you get at
least some of the I guess idea of how
you can develop new techniques to
improve sample throughput yet without
sacrificing data quality that's quite
important for large-scale clinical or
logical studies we think we demonstrate
the first characterization of a sweat
metabolome from screen positive CF
infants the this multiplex separation
technique for us has been really a
game-changer for improving our sample
throughput it allows for actually really
interesting data workflows that reflect
the experiment design and more
importantly you can integrate sort of
high quality QC QA practices to reduce
false discoveries the whole notion here
is your temporal encoding the mass
spectrum through signal pattern
recognition although Sweatt card is
still the remain remains a gold standard
for CF diagnosis you can see that these
new markers actually provide new
insights with the disease
pathophysiology and might be important
for understanding how disease progresses
how it varies from individuals and how
individuals respond to treatment as well
so the most exciting finding from this
work was the unexpect
discovery of these exogenous compounds
the drug and how the infants respond to
the drug used to stimulate sweat and any
prenatal exposures to ubiquitous
plasticizer
also gives us indication of disease
status that it goes beyond the CFC our
primary mutation itself we're currently
doing the same approach for improving
screening for CFS using dried blood
spots as well and do not a long term
birth cohort study as well to basically
predict I guess disease risk in infants
from from again prenatal program as well
and all all the motivation here is about
how we can improve public precision
medicine to prevent disease risk the
early stages of life so with that I want
to thank you for your attention welcome
any questions you might have and thank
again our partners as well as our
sponsors as well thank you thank you for
that insulated presentation before we
get started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button of the little F
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can and
our first question is can you explain
how the zero injection format used in
MSI CMS does not lead to iron
suppression how is this different from
flow injection now ms can and can the
same approach be used in lcms okay um
thanks for the question Marjorie so
let's see I can bring back the slide
earlier in the introduction that might
help explain that question more so this
trace here you can see this is again an
analysis in a multiplex fashion again
seven sampled plugs injected and not
single capillary with a real plasma
filtrate sample so school lots of
residual salts remaining which in this
case if you did the direct infusion of
this plasma filtrate sample it would
lead to suppression you likely would
enable you wouldn't be able to measure
many of the low abundance features or
metabolites present there but
nice thing about the effective the
multiplexed injection format is that the
throughput you can see it's effectively
within 20 to 30 minutes so effectively
the throughput is roughly about 3 to 4
minutes per sample which is on par to
direct infusion so throughput wise it's
comparable to direct infusion mass spec
but the data quality is way more
improved because again you still retain
the separation performance in terms of
resolving isomers but more importantly
for salty samples such as plasma or
urine you can see that the e function is
still is a very good desalter so you
dassault the samples prior to ionization
prior to again of and all the samples
are again entered the ion source offset
in time within a matter of minutes
essentially so it really achieves the
throughput that you get from direct
infusion mass spec yet retains all the
benefits of a separation performance and
more importantly it avoids suppression
because it acts as a really get this
altered hopefully that answers that
question
thank you and the next question is to
all to delete select compounds
associated with cystic fibrosis are not
natural metabolites can they can be can
they be considered authentic biomarkers
for cystic fibrosis yes good point and
that this question has been asked in the
past quite a bit and yeah there this was
a controversial notion essentially
select this slide again the best
performing marker biochemical marker in
this case was in fact pilla cryptic acid
as evaluated based on its physical
Syndicates but also from an air under
curve from a receiver operating
characteristic curve basis yet this
compound is not native to sweat but is
actually a results of the metabolism of
the drug used to simulate sweat so yes
it's not a classic biomarker in the
conventional sense and it might not be
useful to to measure routinely for
diagnosis but I think biomarker from
this standpoint is not only for
diagnosis or prognosis but biomarkers
can also provide insight in terms of
disease pathophysiology or mechanisms of
to disease development this is precisely
what I think both these examples
compounds led us to understand that
these infants not only had CFTR
dysfunctions and how they impacted sweat
chloride transport or sweat thiocyanate
transport for that matter but also they
had other underlying deficiencies and
other enzymes that most likely are
modified or gene modifiers from the same
primary mutation so these infants
normally have problems with sweat
chloride transport but they have
problems metabolizing xenobiotics
essentially including drugs and
environmental exposures so so yeah from
a biomarker standpoint these might not
be quite useful from a diagnostic
standpoint but provide new insights in
terms of disease pathophysiology that's
the whole basis of the non-target
analysis and discovery and in terms of
challenging accepted notions so
certainly in the system drivers as well
hopeful answer their question thank you
for that answer and the next question is
could you clarify how non targeted
metabolite profiling is performed when
using a dilution Tran filter in MSI CMS
for a poorly characterized by fluid such
as sweat okay Thank You Marjorie if I go
to a slide that might show you once
again how that was done and yeah so this
is slide that really illustrates the use
of the dilution trend filter so
essentially um is it very simple it's a
one experiment thing we need to do in
this case so we just do one untargeted
alysus on a pool sample so this is a
pooled sample from the entire cohort so
these are going to be common features
that are present in most individuals at
least the most infants in this
particular case and with the multiplex
injection method because we're injecting
seven samples in a single run we're
going to be injecting again the same
sweat pool sweat sample but now we're
going to encode information through
dilution patterning here so once again
you can see by the dilution pattern on
the left side this is a I can expected
I guess temporal pattern that would
expect for a compound that is president
sweat because for two reasons or for
three reasons
you can see that the blank there's no
signal or no measurable signal in the
blank run that's injection number six
we're confident that this compound is
not an artifact or background signal
more importantly the replicate injection
of the three replicates at the same
dilution can be have really good
precision you can see the CV below is
under five percent so this is a feature
that is not in the blank we can reliably
measure it and importantly it also
undergoes a dilution trends trend as
well so it's a linear dilution trend as
well so we're very confident this
compound which we happen to know in this
case is an authentic compound so this is
how we do feature selection but the
problem is when you do much a feature
extraction typically with non target
analysis is you always challenge in
yourself as how do you differentiate
what is real and what's an artifact and
because the multiplexing ability you
have redundant information so in this
case sometimes we see signals that
happen once even though we've injected
samples seven times and have a blank
sample here you can see the superior
signal has no distinctive pattern so
we're going to exclude this from our
list of features and the funny thing
about electrospray is you generate lots
of these types of spurious signals and
most metabolome workflows they really
don't deal with this type of filter
until later stages of the data
processing here we do it as a first our
very first thing we do is we do remove
spurious signals from the get-go so we
have small a number of features but
features in most cases that were very
very confident with so that's this is
our approach before we do any individual
analysis of samples we do a so called
pollution trend filter on a pooled
sample and basically derive a list of
contents I've been pre vetted
essentially that have been authenticated
for for our purpose at this point we
still don't know which ones are
clinically relevant from the study
design but we just know it either what
they are or even if they're unknown we
know that they're they're real and we
can reliably measure them hopefully that
answers a question
okay we have time for one last question
what are the major limitations of CEMS
technology why is it not more widely
used in metabolomics studies okay thanks
Marjorie it's a good question and it's
true that CMS typically is not widely
used in the metallic field the various
reasons first and foremost I think the
one limitation it has is because you
inject typically 10 nano litters of
sample on column is often a hundred
times less than the typical LC
separation so in terms of concentration
sensitivity the sensitivity and coverage
is generally less than you would get
from LC because you simply inject 100
times less sample on column but that's
also a benefit because if you're dealing
with very small amounts of sample you
can make use of those and actually
inject them reliably so so sensitivity
is limited especially with conventional
sheet liquid interfaces
however those new developments of sheet
lists or low flow interfaces that have
shown improvements in sensitivity other
limitations I think is often seee
has larger I guess variations in
migration time or for chromatography
retention time this is a often a
misperception or misconception in this
case because NCE what's a really
critical parameter is not migration time
but actually electrostatic mobility is
the physical chemical parameter
unfortunately software that's developed
for C still relies on LC based
approaches so in fact this is really the
need for vendors to kind of develop more
software tools that are more suited for
C not for LC so you can easily correct
for variations in migration time by
either having internal standards or
simply measuring electric osmotic flow
so but most people are kind of used to
kind of seen migration times or
retention times and that's how it's
typically presented remember less so so
overall I think sensitivity limitations
and route possibility especially in
terms of migration time are often
perceived limitations for Cee but
there's been some recent work too
to dress those and I think with our
approach but the multiplex and in fact
even if there's time variations it
really doesn't have an impact because
all the samples of area with respect to
each other we're just looking for a
temporal pattern so it really the
normalization or migration time
variations are less critical not
particular case but I think for us this
has been a game changer you can now
increase throughput almost an order of
magnitude this is then you can analyze
samples you couldn't really do readily
with some more large-scale separations
especially for the case for the sweat
samples so for us we had no other
recourse seee was a perfect ideal
technique for this particular case well
that answers your questions I would like
to once again thank dr. Phillip Brits
McKibben for his presentation I'd also
like to thank our sponsors Agilent
Technologies for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through December 2017 you'll
receive an email from laboratory you
when this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time and goodbye thank you
you